he's a 4-time James Beard award-winning
chef who hosts MSNBC's new series what's
eating America airing at 9:00 on Sunday
Andrew Zimmern
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much how you feelin in good
health
fantastic alright don't be shy cuz spit
could come out of your mouth but when I
heard about a virus that started from
someone eating a weird animal I thought
there's only one person to get here get
me the head of Andrew Zimmern
yeah yeah and any regrets about your
life's work someone said no it was
someone said to me earlier today and
because it brings up a couple of really
important issues I think the first one
is I'm a cultural Explorer yes not a
culinary enabler
I learned that in rehab I think the you
know we we practice culinary
ethnocentrism and culinary racism and
have in this country for centuries you
know Chinese restaurant syndrome in the
70s the msg complaints and despite the
fact there's more msg in a can of you
know Campbell Soup than there is in any
Chinese dish in a restaurant in America
a lot of people seem to want to point
fingers and make blame and places that
it is and I think your first guest the
risk/reward guy was talking about that a
little bit I think it's just extremely
unfair playing the blame game does no
one any good I think that playing the
dignity and respect card the most
powerful drug run I have is where we
need okay I think well yeah I've eaten a
lot of weird stuff yes you have yeah and
I may have the antibody to the virus you
might be patient zero no but I take your
point that it's it's the Chinese
certainly have no monopoly on putting
weird stuff in there but there's
something about the human being that
will just put anything in their mouth
yes I don't stand this but our our
digestive systems
I think spoilers we're almost too good
we you can almost eat anything good
culturally we've actually advanced more
than we have physiologically right so
what you have to remember is a couple of
things we've only eaten for pleasure for
a very short amount
the human existence right and in that
pleasure-seeking I mean look at how
unfair and grossly incorrect it is with
25 percent of American children going
hungry at night 24 23 percent actually
depending on who you look at and 24
percent of Americans going hungry we sit
there in applaud at the Nathan's hot dog
eating contest I like hot dogs as much
as the next guy but watching someone
shove 60 of them in his mouth in two
minutes while there are children going
hungry in America night something is
wrong with that we have a perverse love
affair with gimmick eating and gimmick
foods and you know this you know Pizza
fried inside a burger wrapped inside a
burrito dusted with Cheetos we're
killing ourselves with our food I think
there are bigger issues at play here but
you're definitely on to something
because psychologically we seem to have
this desire to put anything into our
mouth that's new and over the last 25
years as food has become this incredible
new sort of rock in American culture I
think it's gotten worse
you like hotdogs I love dogs
okay well I'm not the next guy as much
as the next guy but I take your point
and I other reason I wanted to have you
on is because hearing you talk you sound
like a lot like things I've said over
the last 20 years and I feel like I've
been very lonely you know food has been
a little light motif ever since I've
been on TV even really before that since
the 90s I've talked about the fact that
for example I complained many times
mmm-hmm that until very recently I had
never been to a doctor no matter for
what whoever said to me when seeking
whatever the cure was review what do you
eat it's the main thing that affects our
health and they don't ask us what do you
eat
I could go through a list of Bill Maher
isms when it comes to food and I sit
there and cheer on we both feel the same
way about sure we both feel the same way
about the the diets that we're putting
into our systems and I think it's
extremely apropos right now in what with
the the pandemic that we are enduring
right now the fact of the matter is is
that we're killing ourselves with our
diet right the we're spending
one-and-a-half trillion dollars a year
on the four big food-related diseases
so we know that in general the American
diet is not good for us the American
breakfast that thing at Denny's with the
two eggs for French toast three pancakes
gallon the syrup
scoop of ice cream you know all that
kind of said it's just not good for us
all right we need to be eating less meat
more vegetables eating in a more
nutritious way but eating well in
America has become a class issue and
we're being tested Vantage of there is
such a thing as what I call culinary
lawn darts and it's called corn syrup
it's called processed sugar where people
are making money off of it they're
pushing it on to Americans and we have
addicted people to fat and sugar and
salt and other things in a way that is
criminal know what I mean when they say
when they say that this disease is
especially dangerous to people who are
elderly or with underlying conditions
well the comorbidity issue diabetes
pulmonary cardiopulmonary that's correct
right that's a lot of what the
underlying conditions are people are not
in good health
that's right begin with and it's very
hard to have a health system that
functions even in good times if the
people won't like put a little skin in
the game
that's exactly right but people are
making money off of it big farmers sure
honey often worse the doctors the
hospitals all of that you know what's
that follow the money thing you said
something very interesting about no one
ever asking you about what you've been
right that's in Western medicine in
eastern medicine I when I'm in the Far
East I always go to a see a doctor and
it is the first thing they ask in fact
they interrogate you about it and in
fact what they give you you they don't
they don't send you to a drug store with
the prescription if they feel that
there's something out of whack with you
you get natural homeopathic medicines
things that we ingest that are actually
good for us that our body responds to we
kind of have it a little bit backwards
in this cafe interrogate you yes like
what would you have for breakfast how
often when right I had a doctor in Hong
Kong follow me out the office and across
the street because he
ooh what I did for a living and he
caught me he told me I shouldn't have
this I shouldn't have this I shouldn't
have this and then he caught me eating
it 15 seconds later across the street
it's true story I'm not a great patient
hey are you sure that was about food yes
okay
you